do you think
2021 can uh
could make us feel good about the
trajectory of society
so like where we emerge from this year
feeling good like there's a smile and
there are quests on his face and the
next time we talk
we'll be doing some kind of duet and
guitar and not having this worried
look on our faces no
okay but you've also promised you're
going to somehow end this in a positive
uh positive so okay so how do you how do
you turn the no around what's the u-turn
from the no
no until we get some actually decent
people
in the right chairs who are not
constantly thinking about their next
paycheck
i don't see a solution let me just say
what the
the prerequisites for a solution are and
to let you know why i don't think it's
coming
first of all both of these political
parties the leadership of them
is disgusting and has to go they're
tearing us apart
they lack the will to be americans they
don't understand the subtlety of the
project
they're simply the people who've figured
out how to inhabit the seats
and that is their great achievement
i believe that in order to solve this
you need people who can integrate who
are not partisan
at the level of the partisan warriors
that we're seeing
people who believe in dividing the pies
of the future rather than the present
pie
as our main task as americans because we
are built around growth i'm sorry to say
it
um you need
an ability to have subtle conversations
and you need the ability to exclude
and and you know at the moment everyone
knows inclusion is good
which it isn't it's like saying well
water is good
if i say water is good everybody will
agree with me it's not
people drown people need to
you know get dehydrated it can be
life-saving or life-ending
it it isn't good or bad inclusion is not
good or bad inclusion is just inclusion
exclusion is part of inclusion
we've taught people that they can reason
through the world
as um sub
you know cocker spaniels they just bark
things at each other
you know i'm for safety i'm for
inclusion i'm for growth
oh really do you guys use verbs
dependent clauses are there compound
complex sentences
where are we in this sea of nonsense
you have to be able to build a place
where you have
smart talented people who represent a
diverse
group of correct opinions you need to
get rid of almost all of the people who
have opinions that are
antithetical to what we're trying to
accomplish
you need to give them installation which
we're terrified because we don't trust
anybody so everything has to be
transparent if you're going to the
bathroom i want those walls to be
plexiglas so i can see what you're doing
it's like that's too much transparency
we have
too much and not enough at the same time
and then
you know in essence you need to ensure
that people aren't worried about feeding
their family every four seconds for
being real
none of that is happening and our
billionaires
our billionaires are pathetic what is
the point of billionaires if you're not
going to do
billionaire type cool stuff like saying
fu
and i'm going to throw you know 3
billion dollars at the project of
restoring the national conversation
i i don't grasp this what is the point
of creating obscene wealth if we don't
have anyone smart enough
and caring enough to use it so i agree
with that
that last part for sure let me slightly
push back
on the idea that the leaders themselves
are broken
i feel like this goes to the
joe rogan uh joe biden and trump
having a debate on that program i feel
like
joe biden has a lot of really
interesting ideas
that he's almost forgot how to
communicate he's been fake for so long
within the system hillary was fake for
too long i'm sure she had real ideas at
the beginning that she still was
campaigning on decades later
but like if the system if the platforms
empowered you to search to be honest to
be real to search for those ideas within
yourself
like long-form conversations do then
we even the donald trump and joe biden
leaders we have now
would would take this country to a
better place
that that would unite people so like we
can keep the current congress we just
need to create better platforms it's my
intuit this is
going to the intuition that there's good
in donald trump
there's there is depth and competition
there is good intelligence there is and
the same with joe biden
there's good and joe biden and it's just
we're not incentivizing
but i mean there's several things i
think are broken one of them is twitter
the other is journalism just it's just
the platforms of us communicating with
each other
you